aujourd'hui est un grand jour j'ai
décidé de retrouver mon père je me suis
dit qu'il avait pas pu partir bien loin
à chercher des cigarettes alors j'ai
pris une carte de France et puis j'ai vu
les gorges de Daluis il aimait bien tout
ce qui lui manity Mango me voici partis
sur la route et 7 jours de voyage
seulement plus tard je suis au cœur du
petit Colorado niçois j'ai retrouvé ma
meilleure amie Marie Wilde dit Marie tu
vas être mon ami oh bah choisir je
préfère mourir ainsi que nos guides
Colin et Maxime qui connaissent le coin
comme leur roche alors bonjour à tous je
suis sur le terrain avec Maxou je peux
t'appeler Maxou non est-ce que tu peux
nous raconter la géologie du terrain pas
du tout non
merci Maxou nous voici donc parti tous
les 6 sur les traces de mon papa papa
papa
[Rires]
Maxime on a trouvé des belles qui sont
même mes trois figures géologiques
préférées au monde j'en connais quatre
ce que vous voyez là c'est l'équivalent
de ce qu'on observe à la plage quand la
mer fait apparaître des petits boudins
dans le sable là ce genre de figure ça
s'appelle des rides de courant et ça
peut fossiliser tel quel celle-ci ont
280 millions d'années du coup là on
marche aujourd'hui il y avait une mère
mais j'en ai déjà une un c'est mon père
qu'on cherche alors on va continuer
notre route jusqu'à ses modes cracks
ouais là on est obligé de s'arrêter
parce que ceux qui me connaissent savent
à quel point j'adore ça là on était dans
une pleine lagunaire donc un peu la
transition entre mère mère et un peu
sable comme on peut connaître un peu sur
sur les franges côtières maintenant et
donc là on avait vraiment une de la vase
on avait de l'argile qu'on a connu un
épisode de sécheresse très important ce
qui a permis de craquer cet argile et
donc ce craquement il s'est il est resté
aujourd'hui après 280 millions d'années
dans la pilite il s'est vraiment
fossilisé là comme on peut le voir sur
cette plaque et voilà comment naissent
les mug cracks craquelures debout en bon
français mais les géologues préfèrent
utiliser le terme anglais pour moi
passer pour des blaireaux parce que on
n'a pas trop besoin d'en rajouter mais
c'est pas tout il s'en est passé des
choses à cet endroit et à cette époque
puisque regardez ça c'est exceptionnel
c'est incroyable c'est fantastique ce
sont des gouttes de pluie fossilisées
enfin plutôt des traces de gouttes de
pluie faut imaginer aussi qu'on avait un
climat qui était tropical donc qui dit
qu'il m'a tropicales dit chaleur et
beaucoup de pluie et là c'est ce qui
s'est passé sur cette plaque d'argile
qu'on avait il y a 300 millions d'années
on a une pluie intense type tropicale
qui est tombé sur cette plaque ce qui a
permis de faire du coup les traces de
gouttes de pluie qu'on voit ici et la
pluie c'est interrompue d'un coup ce qui
n'a pas permis le lessivage ensuite de
l'argile donc c'est pour ça que on a le
reste de ses petits fossiles de gouttes
de pluie qui sont restés
merci un avis sur cette explication j'ai
trouvé ça merveilleux merveilleux
m'entendez j'étais déjà emballé par ce
voyage initiatique quand soudain je
découvre cet indice sur le sentier
pas de doute nous sommes sur la bonne
piste papa n'est plus très loin
[Musique]
le papa de la petite Valentine est
demandée dans la réserve le papa de
Valentine merci
[Musique]
mais alors qu'on cherchait mon père
voilà qui on trouve encore une mère
cette fois c'est la mère de toutes les
extinctions c'est le surnom qu'on donne
à l'extinction de masse la plus violente
que la terre est connue du coup juste
derrière moi on peut voir le contact
entre deux roches donc en rouge et la
pellite qui caractérise l'air primaire
donc ça c'est une hergéologique donc qui
est juste derrière moi et au dessus on
peut voir la différence avec une courge
de quartzite plutôt ce contact entre ces
deux roches il caractérise vraiment un
bouleversement géologique il y a environ
250 millions d'années pendant ce contact
il y a eu 95% de la vie qui est a
disparu sur terre
oui vous avez bien entendu jusqu'à 95%
des espèces marines et terrestres rayés
de la carte on sait pas exactement
pourquoi mais si c'est dû un événement
catastrophique une dégradation
progressive des conditions de vie où les
deux à la fois grosso modo on sait juste
que l'atmosphère s'est appauvri en
oxygène et que la température était
chaud bouillante jusqu'à 60 degrés sur
les continents et 40 degrés à la surface
des océans d'après certains chercheurs
ce climat Harry des choses serait dû
d'une part à une activité volcanique
débordante qui aurait recraché plein de
trucs conviviaux dans l'atmosphère comme
du CO2 qui comme chacun sait augmente
l'effet de serre et donc réchauffe le
climat mais une autre cause éventuelle
de ce dérèglement climatique est plus
rigolote la tectonique des plaques
opermiens quasi toutes les terres
émergées se sont rassemblées pour former
la Pangée du coup il y a moins de
kilomètres de côtes et la plupart du
territoire subit un climat continental
pas franchement sympatoche par ailleurs
des chercheurs ont trouvé pas mal de
nickel dans les sédiments de l'époque
nickel qui aurait pu être rejeté par les
volcans très actifs du moment les
trappes de Sibérie et qui auraient pu
empoisonner les végétaux du coup si les
végétaux s'effondre ça se répercute sur
toute la chaîne alimentaire PAM bam bam
bam bam
et paf crise mondiale quel que soit la
ou les causes de cette extinction je
vous rassure même si la vie a mis 100
millions d'années à 100 mètres quand
même elle s'en est remis peu après la
Pangée se disloque pour former la
lorasia au nord et le Gondwana au sud
séparé par l'ouverture de l'une des
premières mères sur terre la tétice
l'ancêtre de la Méditerranée donc là je
me situe littéralement là où la première
mère s'est ouverte c'est fou de se dire
ça non
moi je trouve ça fou
et voilà l'histoire de ce paysage
martien dans lequel la vie a pu
s'adapter et ses Mary White qui va nous
raconter tout ça
vraiment faire ça oui alors Marie les
cailloux ça va 2 minutes mais ça
ressemble à quoi ce qu'il y a dessus et
bah niveau faune et flore c'est assez
particulier sur ce genre de site on sait
que
c'est une roche friable du coup qui
retient peu de nutriments et peu d'eau
du coup on va surtout avoir une flore
comme on retrouve dans les Landes donc
du genévrier du thym des herbes
aromatiques etc et au niveau de la faune
on va avoir vraiment une faune
méditerranéenne et alpine donc on peut
retrouver du chamois comme du lézard
osselé et il y a deux espèces
d'escargots qui sont endémiques ici on a
pu voir ils sont incroyables ces deux
petits escargots qui s'appellent le
marbré des pellites et le maillot des
pays et ils sont vraiment mimétiques
avec la roche ils sont rouges vraiment
tout petit et c'est assez fou on les
retrouve vraiment que ici je vous mets
exactement maintenant des images
d'escargots que j'ai pu filmer ici
essayez de trouver le maillot des
pellites et maintenant essayez de
trouver le marbre et des pilites en vrai
on les voit vraiment bien
ils sont vraiment rouges et collé à la
roche et voilà c'est cool si vous voulez
plus d'informations sur pourquoi mon
chapeau vient de tomber
et sur les machins qui vivent allez voir
la chaîne de Marie Wilde et sa vidéo
n'hésitez pas à liker et mettre des
commentaires et ah la nature bon donc si
je résume on a des figures géologiques
incroyables un pont de l'histoire avec
un rampé l'histoire avec une extinction
de masse et des adaptations du vivant à
ce décor martien mais c'est pas ça qui
va me ramener mon papa heureusement
maximal la solution car au milieu de
tous ces cailloux il y en a qui brillent
plus que d'autres et comme mon papa est
un diamant s'il est quelque part c'est
probablement dans une mine comme par
exemple celle-là donc sur la réserve on
a des mines qui ont été exploités il y a
environ 4500 ans et elles ont continué à
être exploité ensuite à partir à peu
près de il y a 200 ans à peu près et
dedans on a également fait des
découvertes majeures pour la science et
notamment pour la minéralogie il a été
découvert 70 espèces de minéraux dont 9
nouvelles pour la science qui n'avait
jamais été décrit et notamment la Gilles
maritte ou la roue white
alors
bonjour
donc dans ces mines ce qui est assez
exceptionnel c'est qu'on a des filons
qui sont assez conséquents de cuivre
natifs et qui sont des coûts des filons
hydrothermaux reprenons notre vieille
mère la tétine à partir du scénosoïque
la mer commence à se refermer et de se
chamboulement tectonique naît la
ceinture alpine qui s'étend du chalet de
votre tonton savoyarde jusqu'à
l'Himalaya et au-delà vous imaginez bien
que le mouvement pareil c'est à cause du
grabuge dans les cailloux du coin et
notamment dans la région la surexcion
des Alpes a créé des tas de fractures
dans la roche fracture dans lesquelles
on circulé des fluides chargés
d'éléments comme le cuivre l'arsenic
l'argent ou le mercure ces éléments sont
ensuite déposés dans les fentes et qui
s'appelle Rio filon hydrothermales
j'avais très envie de voir ça en vrai
surtout que parmi les minerais de cuivre
qu'on trouve là-bas la malachite et la
zurite font partie de mes trucs préférés
alors imaginez les voir dans leur
habitat naturel ça me titille un peu
mais on n'a pas pu aller voir les
grottes en question vu que bah faut y
aller en rappel et que j'avais pas très
envie de mourir alors Maxime nous a
emmené plutôt là une autre grotte dans
laquelle on aurait pu voir ça ça et ça
mais à la place on a vu plein d'autres
trucs
vas-y c'est parti
comme une naissance mais à l'envers
Nicolle comme ça
on est vraiment dans une mine qui était
exploitée avant pour le cuivre il venait
comme ça quatre
et ils ont pas eu d'être creuser un peu
plus haut parce que c'est pas juste
[Musique]
c'est des signes de soufre qui c'est
pour ça que c'est jaune c'est magnifique
c'est d'ailleurs grâce aux choses que le
cuivre a pu se former avec la natifs
tellement d'espèces qui sont mortes là
[Musique]
ça va je te donne pas parfait
reflétant sur cette journée je me
trouvais tout soudain mitigé en Montfort
intérieur mon cœur de géologue était
ravi d'avoir pu croiser tant de
curiosité mais Marat de fille se posait
encore trop de questions
où était mon père pourquoi était-il
parti se souvenait-il de moi
avait-il refondé une famille
quelle est la conductivité thermique du
cuivre
combien de tiens valent mieux que toi tu
l'auras
[Musique]
je m'apprêtais à renoncer le cœur gros
et les pièces en poulet quand soudain ma
vie parce que
[Musique]
on fait pas ça dans les rivières merde
les poissons
[Musique]
dizaine de jours de 1928 heures que je
vous offre c'est presque une demi
grossesse et c'est aussi le temps qui
s'écouler réellement quand vous ouvrez
Tik Tok juste pour 5 minutes donc oui
quatre mois offerts contrairement aux
femmes qui l'ont bien mérité cette offre
est imbattable alors n'hésitez plus à
aller tout de suite sur
norvpn.com/s de comptoir ou cliquez sur
le lien en description de la vidéo
nordvpn.com/s
merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout
cette aventure altente mais ce n'est pas
fini car le deuxième volet de cette
trilogie en deux épisodes et chez Barry
White on se retrouve là-bas tout de
suite
trois mots pour définir ta chaîne
ok ça fait un biodiversité et truite
[Musique]